marc-antoine le bret c'est le zoom
lebret tout de suite à 19h05 sur ces
vitesses
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour je crois qu'on avec jean marc
généreux je crois que vous avez une
bonne nouvelle jean marc j'appelle pour
vous dire que je vais sur 30 et aline et
la propre vie pour moi danse avec les
stars que personne pollet j'en avais
plein jour plus que quatre à ricardo
maintenant je vais animer l'émission est
acquis les réussir j'achète aux jaloux
tu aurais vingtaine de voitures en
plateau s'il vous plaît les commissaires
scpn qui sont là eu mes chances comme
l'île boulay ch avec des raquettes à
neige parce que j'aime apporter mission
accomplie merci marc antoine
marc-antoine avec nous il faudrait qu'un
petit pas plus de retour je vous le dis
voilà il avait perdu son micro on
m'appelle il avait perdu son micro et
bien sûr ceux qui sont originaux perdre
leur travail
c'est d'une logique arables
sortez benaïssa quelque chose parler lui
non mais il a envie de bien faire oui
mais non non non mais c'est une fin mais
sans rigoler c'est fou ça l'intérim est
juste oui c'est vrai on a le docteur
michel cymes aussi par zoom michel cymes
qui est avec nous oui bonsoir si cher
oui ça va très bien série bon c'est
mieux avec un micro à ils ont oublié de
me mettre un micro bienvenue sur ces
huit bons soirs où ce soir tout alors
cyril eu hier soir j'ai animé les
pouvoirs extraordinaires du corps humain
et en parlant de sexualité avec adriana
karembeu j'ai découvert que son corps un
pouvoir extraordinaire
il peut faire rétrécir mon slip
d'ailleurs cyril est ce que vous
connaissez le point commun entre le
professeur raoul tu es moi même nom
c'est quoi on a tous les deux une queue
de cheval et pourtant j'ai les cheveux
courts et nouvelle honda nouvelles de
nagui
nagui qui embrasse tout à fait une
découverte cette semaine il a fait une
découverte cette semaine m'a dit je
crois au jour bonjour bonjour
métro oui c'est lille je viens
d'apprendre que la chaîne france o avait
fermé alors je voulais quand même dire
bravo bravo bravo parce que j'ai regardé
les cours mais figurez-vous que france ô
depuis qu'elle a fermé et ben il fallait
même tonio on stocke quand elle était
ouverte et ça chapeau djadja ces maisons
j'adorerais
j'adorais français regardez les prix ils
en parlent et un instant on a la chance
d'avoir avec nous celui qui a fait
parler de lui ces derniers mois c'est le
professeur raoult
bonsoir professeur professeur vous à
nous faire un petit point on voit qu'il
a on voit qu'il n'a pas eu trop de temps
[Rires]
un petit point sur le virus un choix je
n'avais pas de micros mais il n'y a pas
de budget non plus voilà non mais vous
savez que que je devrais vous appelez
professeur hanouna alors puisque quoi
nous occuperons tous les deux de malades
ce sont mes patients et vous vos
chroniqueurs c'est vrai de plus vous
pratiquez comme moi des milliers de
tests de chroniqueurs mais on sait très
bien que dans les deux cas on en revient
toujours au même dans quinze jours moi
je vais vous ressortir la chloroquine et
vous vous allez nous ressortir benhaim
et son brushing est sonné et jean-michel
et satom
merci et on est maintenant avec ma tsb
mac lesggy kelly adore match et si elle
est amoureuse de lui en secret de mac
lesggy d'ailleurs c'est à bonsoir mac
vous allez répondre à une question qu'on
se pose tous je crois à ce soir bonjour
c'est mac lesggy égale m sus ses
familiales oui comme dit benhaim ou je
ne sais pas qui effectivement vous êtes
nombreux à me demander qu'est ce que
c'est cette histoire de ligne de
vêtements de cyril hanouna
oui et bien c'est très simple et nous
allons résoudre cette équation grâce aux
mathématiques et mais fameuse équation
de ftp
tout d'abord il faut savoir que cyril
hanouna égale trois cinquièmes de
vendeurs de roses plus l'un d'eux me
pâquis plus 6/8 de patrick sébastien x
d'arca / douce tiers de palma et
maintenant passons à l'équation de rtt
du jour à savoir vêtements 2 cyril
hanouna égale pyjama fois survêtement
fois gitans plus chanel fois lopez du 36
plus chakchouka / chic plus discrétion
voire asra et voilà cqfd l'époque - 12
[Applaudissements]
il avait parce que là on aura toujours
un invité mystère est l'invité mystère
de ce soir bonsoir invité mystère c'est
une beauté
[Musique]
comment sont les messins ont pourtant
des oui toi sartec à toi jeune
entrepreneur du paf
euh tu souhaite rejoindre l'élite de la
nation des émissions télé et rejoindre
une équipe en pleine d'art cas où tu
préfère manger du som à tous les repas
avec ta grand-mère lara sera et arthur
moi je pense mon chéri la question elle
est dite répondu
il joue le père fouras ça à mon chéri
jada la question est vite répondu et
chérie rejoint tpp c'est une émission de
ou froid la salle et chérie on est en
direct ça va
[Applaudissements]